justice has been served up in california
this week as prominent democrat donor ed
buck has finally been convicted
in the overdose deaths of two gay black
men but one thing is missing
outrage from the left the side that says
black lives matter is conspicuously
silent
when two black lives are lost many
believe it's because of ed buck's
connections
buck has donated thousands to well-known
democrat politicians including barack
obama ted lou and hillary clinton
maybe this is why the left is so quiet
but one person who has refused to let
the story fall on deaf ears
is our next guest jasmine kanek she
joins me now
jasmine uh a great deal of work of being
an activist
and and caring about things is quiet
anonymous work
you never get credit for anything you
stuck to it you have victory with this
finally getting this monster off the
streets
tell us how it feels and what why what
your sense is about why it took so long
well i'm a journalist and a political
strategist i'm not necessarily an
activist but i know this seems like
activisty work
we've been at it for four years you know
two men have died countless others
almost
died it is such a humongous
relief to know that ed buck will never
be on the streets again and you're
absolutely right
i am an elected member of the democratic
party i am so
disappointed in my party they have had
very little to say about this whole
entire ordeal over the past four years
some even wanting to give ed buck the
benefit of the doubt
it's embarrassing it's very very
frustrating but it also is an
opportunity for us to have a
conversation
about the difference between actually
doing the work and paying lip service to
the work right so you can't just say
black lives matter
and then when countless black men are
being preyed upon
by uh you know one of our donors turned
the other way we didn't do that with
harvey weinstein we haven't done that
with other people
and i know good and well if ed buck had
been a republican donor
they would have been screaming bloody
murder and so i need for my party for
the party that claims that black people
are so important to its
uh to its mission and to its values to
act like it when someone is killing us
you know and this is i have to say
weinstein did get away with it for so
long
because the argument was don't do
anything it'll affect the issues
we'll lose money and that seems to be
the play there
which which is shocking and especially
it took
with the bodies were being taken out of
this guy's apartment
and everyone was looking away except i
i have to say i think activists should
be on your cv
uh i think it's a it's a good thing to
be but but at the same time
it's a voice from within the democratic
party democrats don't want this
this is not what any classical liberal
thinks is all right
and also you've made a point and i want
to get to this about how
homelessness poverty push people to
desperation
allowing monsters like ed buck to prey
on people to have an easier time
tell us about that look i am in the
heart of downtown l.a where all i see
every day is nothing but black men on
the corner laying on the corner laying
on the street black men and women
we are the number we are the face of
homelessness in the city and county of
los angeles
ed buck was only able to do what he did
because of our homelessness exactly
because people felt like they could they
had to play russian roulette
with their life with this person just to
get money for food or just to have a
place to sleep
for the night that wasn't outside and
that's a shame we
have to talk about that we have to take
our head out of the sand
and stop acting like this didn't happen
or it's going to happen again
and and republicans have got to stop
seeding
these issues to a party that clearly has
abandoned
the entire dynamic this is what all of
us have an interest in we're united in
this thank you very much jasmine
great work and congratulations now hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else